thank you very much Jerry fantastically
generous introduction could I first ask
all those who know that they are
volunteers to start moving and block all
the exits please you know who you are
there are stewards and marshals waiting
for you ladies and gentlemen brothers
and sisters comrades and Friends you
probably thought you'd already paid to
come here and I know that I haven't
drawn the most popular straw in being
the one who stands between you and gnome
and the question-and-answer session but
the fact is that we've covered action
quarterly are quite old hands and have
been in this business a long while and
we're not about to let a captive
audience get away that lightly we would
like you to make a pledge if you can and
will be passing buckets and baskets
around for you to put money in or IOUs
or checks or any kind of paper currency
I don't know for example if I can just
start the ball rolling here
how many people here would put their
hands up and admit that they pay for
home delivery of the Washington Post
that's quite a lot I do it too I reckon
what $250 a year for that I don't see
why the government doesn't distribute it
free quite frankly 250 for to have a
Great War of consensus dumped on your
doorstep now if you're paid 250 and not
really notice it for that the newspaper
that publishes Henry Kissinger as an
op-ed contributor the newspaper of which
I have Stern once rather brilliantly
said it's a great paper The Washington
Post you never know on what page you'll
find the front-page story that paper who
will put up their hand and say they'll
give 250 dollars they'll give the
Washington Post equivalent there you go
into the bucket it goes anymore yes
excellent any more of those well you can
keep them you can keep thinking about it
the offer is not it was not going to
expire with time while you're writing
your check or your pledge or your I owe
you or just tugging that your billfold I
just like to say a few thing
about our guest of honor tonight and
about and about caq I was rereading
Norman Mailer's armies of the night
recently preparation for an interview I
was doing with him and I came across the
wonderful passage where Mailer is
arrested in the march on the Pentagon
and is thrown into the wagon by the
police who then throw in a member a
uniformed member of the u.s. Nazi Party
in along with him just to show that the
Park Police have a sense of humor and as
the sort of scene clears a bit and he
made a realizes there's him and the Nazi
and one other a sort of thin rather
distant spectacle slightly Jewish
looking sort of academic guy and he says
that it's turns out to be Noam Chomsky
and I went interviewed him later I said
that must have been an amazing country
said yes at the time I had no idea who
Noam Chomsky was but now of course was
was from the first days of the anti-war
movement not just on the day of that
great march on the Pentagon but on many
other days important days too in their
very front rank taking the side of the
victim calling an aggression by its
right name calling people to the
responsibility the realization that in
such a case of aggression
you'll morally obliged to stand with the
victim and that contribution I think
will be remembered he's often
pessimistic about the historical record
I nonetheless think his contribution on
that will will always be remembered as
as quite literally imperishable he was
also there at the funeral of Fred
Hampton was almost the only white face I
think who was present at that funeral
the victim being an assassinated
dissident victim of a national political
police force the Federal Bureau of
Investigation he went all the way to
Managua to offer his solidarity in
practical and moral forms as a lecturer
and as a and as a friend at the time of
the historical war of aggression waged
against against Nicaragua by the Reagan
administration and he's also incredibly
helpful open willing and friendly for
the least person who wants to consult
him for research and scholarly purposes
I I recently felt I had to do something
about the Charles Mary Richard
Herrnstein phenomenon the Belko
phenomena where it's suddenly discovered
that the fault is not in the society
but in the genetic makeup of its lower
orders and I thought well probably none
will have something to say about this
after all he studied the nature-nurture
question rather intently and I rang him
up said what have you got he said well
not much recent really but I suppose I
did write the paper about Richard
hansteen concertina is really the author
the late Herrnstein rather than charles
murray
of the Belko a few years ago he sent me
the most the most perfect and most
prescient demolition of Richard hansteen
that it was possible to imagine this was
a time when everybody in the country was
reviewing that damn book and where the
book was getting really pretty extensive
free ride and where none of these
insights and none of these findings and
none of these areas of contestation were
alluded to at all by the supposedly
scholarly reviewers but you only had to
contact the man himself and to be shall
I say without sounding fawning
enlightened he almost been the victim
he's not himself a victim of self-pity
in any way wouldn't say this for himself
but I can tell you as someone who's
followed here that he's been the victim
of a really unprecedented campaign of
calumny and defamation and a parallel
campaign to silence and excluded
marginalised his contributions his books
go unreviewed in the major outlets his
letters often in written in defense
against appalling libels often
unpublished or published in a mutilated
form I think he's born under borne up
under this with tremendous dignity and
bearing and and address my chomskyan
syllogism therefore if I can venture
such a thing is that he has always been
there for us and covert action quarterly
will always be it is here for him and so
give generously how's it going is there
anyone who hasn't had the bag onto their
nose yet and there must be some people
at the front I think all right let's see
I want to increase the tempo of giving a
little if what I've just said doesn't
move you or stir you how much would you
give to see Barbara Bush in the dock
okay where any member of the Bush family
I'm offering you Barbara I had to review
her ghastly book the other day
you can always do something you know
however small i had to review this down
book for a stupid tabloid reading
through and she said that Phillip Agee
had given away the name of an American
agent in Athens who later been
assassinated and was morally responsible
for this man's murder and the
introduction says that George Bush read
every word of the book to protect her
from having made any mistakes or
committed any errors of fact so I
thought huh rank Phil in Hamburg I said
I think you were too sewer and he is
suing now and they've already admitted
that they're wrong this is good you want
anyone want the buckets back alright
another pledge he's going to his circle
several million dollars the publishers
already admitted and the author their
guilt in the matter by changing this and
excising the libel from the paperback
and our old friend Phil o stands
actually to be vindicated in the
American Court and she might have to
come there and take pend it I'd say
what's that worth to you I'd say it was
worth a few by few bucks
one of those things that cheers you up
give generously in other words when when
Phil first started writing about this
kind of thing it amazes me looking at
his book now the scandal or it caused we
had no idea he thought it was bad
Phil edgy helped us to find out how bad
but we and he had not the least idea how
bad it really was it's since his
revelations that we've discovered about
frat that we've had Jennifer harbors
revelations of the collusion direct
collusion between the CIA and the death
squads in Guatemala that we've had
brilliantly reported also in covert
action quarterly the account of the
CIA's part in the arrest of Nelson
Mandela the original arrest that led to
his his first trial and imprisonment and
the arrest of his wife Winnie we've had
the gladiator evolutions about the plans
for military crews in every Western
European country in the event of crisis
we've had the Ames Fiasco where it seems
the taxpayers were paying to have the
United States just inform itself thus I
suppose cutting out the middleman and
now the revelations that the crystal
ball and stargazing faction is
considered to be worth seventeen million
of anybody's money I've always thought
one often wondered why the Washington
Post has an astrology column and
a scope every day now I think I know it
was code they were talking to each other
through the Washington Post astrology
columnist anyway think of think about
that and see much how much money you can
part with caq has always had the goods
on the the foul collusion between the
national security state in this country
and a network of dictators and
psychopathic killers who are ready to
rent themselves out to them i have very
often have been lucky enough to be able
to recommend visiting journalists from
overseas to go to the caq library to go
through the archive to write stories in
the foreign press that the sort that you
never see here it's a it's a service
they're very proud and glad to provide
and I'm incredibly proud and glad to be
able to recommend great satisfaction
comes of it
so what's it what's it worth to you is
my question as I hope we can have one
more go-around perhaps I can pluck one
more heart string right for one more
pocket open one more bill Phil did you
see in The Washington Post yesterday
that dr. Michael Mandelbaum great
foreign policy pundit of the Brookings
Institution has issued his final
critique of the Clinton administration's
foreign policy this is one that not even
know my think would have believed in his
in his critique of our um our
vulnerability to our own good intentions
but dr. Malabar really does say the
problem with the Clinton administration
is its foreign policies it's so
compassionate it is the foreign policy
says this doctor the Brookings
Institution of Mother Teresa now if you
take my view of Mother Teresa
which is that she's a valet de pouvoir
that she's a servant of right-wing thugs
in power and right-wing businessmen on
the make and someone who likes to fool
the poor I suppose you could say that
this was the foreign policy of Mother
Teresa well I don't think that was the
implication about either her or
President Clinton but it is I think
still and perhaps now we'll agree that
the benchmark remark about about how we
are really much too kind much too sweet
nostril to has taken much to forgiving I
will close with a story that I have
known will forgive me telling about him
as we all Casely do we had to go to the
dentist not long ago now the dentist
said to him it's okay your teeth are in
good shape but you're grinding them
rather a lot aren't you no I'm said no
no
I don't I'm not aware of grinding them
at all well said the dentist I've heard
that before
actually what's happening this is common
to you as you're grinding them in your
sleep
you know I'm thought maybe I am his wife
and great partner wondered the wonderful
Carol Chomsky agreed to sort of have a
rather clock Noam watch just to sort of
see walls
he wasn't grinding them in his sleep so
they had a more intensive watch they
found he was grinding them for a 15 20
minute period every day in the morning
while he was going through the New York
Times now I would just in closing there
for a recall for you the great closing
words from the late martyr of the
movement Joe Hill don't grind be like
Noam organized by thang
okay your turn I think there's some mics
up here yeah
dr. Chomsky if you could discuss the
current situation in Nicaragua and
comments a bit on the split in the
sandanista movement and also the the
follies of the Chamorro government hmm
well let me give you two versions of
what's going on in aggregate one of them
was given by Hillary Clinton who was
down there on round mid-october uh
and I think she should least stopped at
the airport maybe she saw something else
and she praised the president tomorrow
on having I think her words were
reunified the Nicaraguan family and revé
unn I don't control it
unn close your eyes I've been blinded
for the last two hours
she praised them for her for
revitalizing the economy and reunifying
the Nicaraguan family very upbeat
uh I happened to be there at the time I
have a daughter and grandson there and I
was visiting and a couple of days before
about three or four days earlier the
there's an ultra-right newspaper the
newspaper the business community the big
glossy newspaper the business community
the Tribuna and they had had an article
which was a which was on a UNICEF report
that had just come out which I haven't
seen reported here on Nicaragua which
and their headline said Nicaragua is
mortgaging its future and may be
destroyed why because 75% of families
live in extreme poverty at 25% of
children suffer severe malnutrition 1/3
of children between 6 and 9 don't go to
school the country is collapsing and has
been falling into total
ruin since the United States took it
over in 1990 so there's two versions you
can pick the version of UNICEF and the
right-wing business community in
Nicaragua you can pick Hillary Clinton's
version in fact it you know there are a
lot of third-world countries if you've
been around the third world where it is
possible to sort of drive around and
think you're in a rich country I mean in
Cairo for example you can go from the
airport to the fancy hotel on the Nile
and you know some fancy restaurant and
so on and you think you're on
you know Upper West Side Manhattan or
wherever the rich area of Manhattan is I
don't know or the equivalent part of
Washington you can do that Managua is
not one of them you can't go two blocks
without seeing that the country is
desperate without having your car
surrounded vais starving Street waves
asking for a penny or seeing that you
know the place is falling to pieces and
if you bother looking any further you
see that it's not impossible as a few
Nicaraguan environmentalists are fearing
that the country may be uninhabitable in
a couple of decades because people are
so poor that they're forced to go up and
cut trees and there's deforestation and
of relatively underpopulated and
resource rich area to the extent that
lakes are beginning to dry up and rivers
are drying up and there's environmental
catastrophes and so on and that's after
a decade of whatever you think about the
Sandinistas no doubt of rather
significant progress by Central American
Standard is astonishing progress well ok
take your choice about what's happening
I've already forgotten the second half
of the question well des split in the
center this line of Milton's and the
nest is well I'm in the sand Ernest as
I've plenty to answer for uh the good
thing about the sand honest I was very
critical of myself that some of you will
know right through the 80s and with
plenty of conflicts but there was one
good thing about several good things
about them first of all they didn't go
around massacring everybody which by the
standards of our colonies is already
pretty good you know so they get a
couple of points for that
secondly they did provide space in which
other people could do things so if
people wanted to carry out health
programs or you
to make a school for the poor or
cooperative or something yeah they'd
help him out and they could do it again
by the standards of our dependencies
that's unheard of in fact kind of hard
to find here but so there were good
things about them on the other hand they
were authoritarian and they robbed and
they did plenty of ugly things the right
now the party has split split as a funny
word for I mean the official party which
has almost every least by the polls
that's almost all of the people who
support it is the Ortega faction Surya
Ramirez who I should say is a personal
friend is separated he was the vice
president he's now writing uh he's kind
of a kind of like a mainstream social
democrat uh is got a separate grouping
that's the son Dennis to split exactly
what it means in the situation the
country is very hard to say you it
doesn't make any sense to interpret the
results of elections in Central America
for very well-known reasons very well
understood reasons which were pointed
out years ago by Central American
Jesuits and that is as they pointed out
that the culture of terror has
domesticated people's aspirations
you just place people under repeated
terror year after year and it
domesticates their aspirations they
don't even hope for anything anymore
you've killed hope in the title of a
recent book by somebody is here the that
and that's that's the great achievement
of the United States to have killed hope
so people just sort of try to find
survival strategies and hence the
results of elections are almost meanings
even when people vote may I ask that you
restate the question because the
microphones are not wired into the loop
system thank you
yeah ok well I'll try to keep the
question very brief you alluded to the
fact that the US has cut back on the
foreign aid and cutting back to the UN
because the Cold War is over and they
don't have to give the bribes
anymore and then you said you were going
to not what I said well no it's we never
had a bridezilla right okay that's true
let's turn we always had the most
miserly aid program right that's true
but and but it has something to do with
the end of the Cold War and that the
domestic situation also has something to
do with the end of the Cold War you know
having to do with the fact that you
don't need the labor movement anymore to
you know to subvert the labor movements
overseas and you don't of course you
don't need the labor movement at all
because you've got slave labor around
the world and so on what I wanted to ask
is can you give us a thumbnail sketch of
what you're going to talk about tomorrow
for those of us who are going to be
snowbound
didn't know about the snow if you're
snowbound I'll be - the question was I
was asked to repeat the questions the I
think there's a little bit of
misinterpretation but let me state the
question as it was stated and then I'll
try to deal with the misinterpretation
maybe my fault I the questioner said
that I had implied or maybe said that
the end of the Cold War has led to
cutback in US aid because it's not
necessary to bribe countries and it's
led to attack on the labor movement
because we no longer leade need the
labor movement to undermine labor in
other countries and other things like
that and then was asked for a thumbnail
sketch of what I'm going to talk about
tomorrow for those of you who are snow
bound that's news to me I thought it
never snowed in Washington the first of
all I didn't say if I if I implied it
was my fault but I didn't mean to imply
that these things had to do with the end
of the Cold War the end of the Cold War
has happened but I think that's a very
minor factor in what's going on these
changes have been going on very
dramatically for about 25 years and they
have to do with big changes in the
International economy the huge explosion
of financial capital ever since Richard
Nixon dismantled the Bretton Woods
system and the system of regulated
capital which is an extraordinary
phenomenon the increased possibilities
of globalization of production I mean
there's a number of things that have
gone on it's true that the cold end of
the Cold War contributed to them the end
of the Cold War
contributed to them primarily here I
think you have to think about what the
Cold War was about in my view what
that's mostly misinterpreted in my view
the Cold War was just a very overblown
case of a north-south conflict it's kind
of like the u.s. conflate with grenaded
we go to the opposite extreme but of
course there's a big difference between
a speck of in the Caribbean that you
can't find in a six of the world one of
them you get rid of in a weekend and the
other takes seventy years but the
structure is quite similar Russia and
Eastern Europe generally were
third-world deeply impoverished
third-world areas for the most part
parts were part of the West and they're
going back to the West like the Czech
Republic in western Poland yeah that was
part of the West and that's going back
to the West most of it was deeply
impoverished third-world countries in
fact the original third world you know
it started splitting from Western Europe
around the 15th century getting
increasingly more deeply impoverished as
the West began to develop and be its
service area kind of like the relation
between us in Mexico or something like
that well there's some rules of
international conduct one major rule is
that no part of the third world is of
the South so-called has allowed the
strike and independent courts that's not
permitted they have a function their
function is to serve they try to carry
out an independent course whether it's
you know fishing cooperatives and
Grenada or a populist program in Haiti
or you know you name it you know clinics
and health care in Nicaragua they got to
be smashed because that's not permitted
when it's in a six of the world even
more and in fact the u.s. attack the
Western attack began in 1918 that's when
a cold war begin the Russia wasn't
conquering anybody whatever you thought
about it the there's a second rule of
international affairs and that is you
better it's bad enough to strike an
independent course it's worse -
apparently succeed now succeed means
maybe not you know there's no objective
measure of success success means succeed
in a way which will be
which will motivate others to try to do
the same thing and the fear of Russia
from 1918 right until the mid 1960s and
that's when our record runs dry you know
we don't have a Declassified record
after that but as from 1918 right away
until the mid early 1960s the great fear
was that they were successful that they
were again they were having a
demonstration effect that others would
want to follow and in fact if you think
realistically that's not mistaken people
here say look what a horror was compared
at the Western Europe that's true it was
a total horror but to compare it with
Western Europe is absolute insanity you
know I mean that's like saying that the
Cambridge Massachusetts kindergartens
are a failure and proof ask how much
quantum physics the kids know as
compared with the ones getting their
page these at MIT I mean that's not even
insane you know you want to compare
Eastern Europe and something compare
compare it with something that was
comparable before the this took this
took place so say compare Russia and
Brazil or compare Bulgaria and Guatemala
or something like that that's a same
comparison and there's a good reason why
nobody undertakes it if you have a look
at Brazil and Guatemala and the rest of
them you'll see why nobody undertakes
that comparison except people in the
third world we don't have good education
z' like us they do make that comparison
and planners in the united states always
made that comparison in the West and
they were afraid of what they found that
in comparison with what we're doing this
stuff looks pretty successful and others
are going to try to follow it and that
Henry Kissinger had a word for it it's a
virus that will infect others and he was
talking about Chile under a yen day it
was going to be a virus that would
infect people as far as Italy not
because Chile was going to conquer Italy
but because it would send the wrong
message the Italian voters namely you
can vote for a social democratic system
and maybe it'll work and when there's a
virus you got to destroy it and
inoculate everything around it and
that's what we did that's you look over
that that's basically the Cold War okay
it's over
so Eastern Europe goes back to what it
was pretty much no not 100% but the
parts that were part of the West are
becoming part of the West the parts that
were third-world are becoming
third-world and that is that does
contribute to these other phenomenon it
means for in fact that you read the
business press they're very frank about
it the business press which is the best
place to if you want to read the press
that's the one that usually comes close
to telling the truth they tell you that
with Eastern Europe now back in its
third world situation or to put it let
me quote from the Financial Times in
London the world's greatest business
newspaper the with the impoverishment
and pauperization of East Europe as a
result of the capitalist reforms the
Western investors can now move their
production over to Eastern Europe and
undermine the pampered Western workers
who will be forced to give up their
luxurious lifestyles so now in other
words not only can GM and you know VW
and so on invest in Mexico and you know
Brazil and so on but they can also do it
in Poland where they furthermore get
well educated healthy trained people
because this part of the third world did
develop and they can do it at 10 percent
the cost of the pampered Western
European workers without any benefits
and incidentally since none of these
guys believe in the free market and
never have free markets for others not
for yourself they insist on high tariff
protection and you know subsidies from
the government and the usual stuff that
comes along with foreign investment so
in that respect yes it's another weapon
in the hands of Western power to
undermine the pampered Western workers
so the S the Cold War has an effect but
it's a you know it's a not a big effect
and that as with regard to aid it's
virtually nothing what am I going to
talk about tomorrow well what I'm going
to talk about tomorrow is the rollback
on the domestic scene I think it's going
on the United States is in effect being
subjected to a kind of a structural
adjustment program it's being turned
into a third world Society now it's
so rich you know has so many advantages
in fact : parallel this ought to be by
far the most richest if there's one
hungry child in the United States the
socio-economic system is a total
catastrophe consider given the given the
wealth of this country it's not like
other places you want to know how
wealthy it is I'll give you just one
figure in the 18th century 18th century
the life expectancy of Americans that
level of life expectancy was not reached
by the upper classes and Britain until
this century you know the next richest
people in the world that's one measure
of the extraordinary privilege and
advantages that there are here and in
fact so we're being turned into a kind
of third world Society but you know it's
the United States it's not Haiti and
that's happening all over you can't walk
through any American city without
recognizing a third world city sector of
great opulence you know a large group of
people actually the majority who are
suffering or maybe in misery and a big
massive superfluous people you have to
get rid of all souls church wherever it
is anyway that's what we do the
president Chomsky is honored to share
again this Thomas Paine's with you as
your greatest student
I had to inquire the technique of our
intellectual endeavor we ought to review
the responsibility of intellect dot ESD
uncorruptible one why have we fail to
persuade the majority as sinner to take
the necessary action disengaging
themselves from discipline of benevolent
non benevolent but a banal and on no
more sation of evil also as known as a
cultural relativism that has
historically haunted our condition and
here's a case of in point our richard
rulings reply to your letter Richard
William wo Li n you wrote a letter
and he says despite the considerable
itical and culture means at the disposal
of opinion makers in politician most
citizen remain contra our Chomsky
surprisingly capable of penetrating the
veil of DC and making up at their minds
um dan CIL's so what if all citizens are
aware it has a repression from the
systemic mechanism of economic political
control enslave us to the rich and the
powerful so the question is why
you know if why we are if I got it
correctly why we're unable to convince
the majority of people to look at things
the way we think the world is and are
the mechanisms of control so powerful it
can't be broken so I believe all techne
ought to be look at to and see see I
don't agree with the assumption I think
most of the populations on our side in
fact I think the evidence is
overwhelming about that so take for
example like I mentioned one case the I
only mentioned one case in fact when I
was talking about public opinion in
policy I mentioned several catches take
the case I mentioned one of them is the
Vietnam War that's a big issue there has
been thirty you know by now forty fifty
years of intense propaganda about the
Vietnam War all of which says it was a
noble effort that went maybe went wrong
70% of the population says it was
fundamentally wrong and immoral not a
mistake
despite that massive propaganda despite
never having heard anyone say that
meaning everyone picked it up on their
own somehow take say the Pentagon budget
the one part of the budget that's going
up well the popular I'm against that and
so are the population by six to one it's
not a small amount
takes a budget balancing big thing you
know we're all supposed to assume and
take for granted that you got to balance
the budget in fact the political system
is is bounded you know there are
differences some guys say seven years
some guys say eight years you know so
that's the menu debate that in the
political system and the you listen to
NPR and the
the Americans voted for a balanced
budget and so on well the fact that here
the polls you got to look at a little
bit carefully because they're
well-crafted there's one question asked
for headline writers and there's another
question asked for people who want to
know what public opinion is like so you
know how to frame the messages in which
you deceive people those are different
questions the question for the headline
writers is would you like a balanced
budget and most everybody says sure you
know that's like asking people would you
like your mortgage to disappear terrific
you know I like my mortgage disappear so
you get a big high number okay that's
for NPR and you know the editorial
writers and so on everybody wants a
balanced budget
then comes the other question which is
for the propagandists who have to figure
out how to frame this so people don't
know what's hitting them and that says
would you like that begins to ask the
rational questions like would you what
would you want your household debts
eliminated if it means giving up your
house or your car or your children's
education and so on well then everybody
no no I don't want a balanced household
budget anymore so when you ask that
question the same question do you want
the budget balanced if it means cuts in
health expenditures or you know social
spending or environment so on well then
populations opposed by you know three to
one or something depending on exactly
how the question is framed so in fact
the population is overwhelmingly opposed
to a balanced budget
now you're not allowed to know that
you're supposed to think everybody wants
a balanced budget
you know Clinton when he responds to the
Republicans as of course of course we
have to balance the budget you know okay
well they're the population again and in
fact you know you could ask the question
who's right I mean there is a factual
question is the population right or is
the whole political elite right well you
know I think there's good evidence about
that and I think the population is right
but that's another question in fact let
me just end with this not I do I think
the populations on our side so do so
does concert as the right-wing Congress
so does the wall street journal' they
all think the populations are saw on our
side and there's proof of it actually my
latest an article and cover
action quarterly where I ended up giving
some evidence about this the evidence
that I cited was the probe there's a
program in Congress called defunding the
left okay and you know the Wall Street
Journal has big articles about it how we
got to defund the left and Congress is
pushing through you know legislation
which will be fund the left well take a
look at who they've got to defund and
what they're worried they say it looks
really terrible the government's funding
all these left-wing organizations we
ought to stop that all right take a look
at the list the top organization of the
left
that has to be defunded is Catholic
Charities the reason why is because
there are priests and nuns who for
nothing are going out and working with
poor people to try to help them deal
with the fact that they don't have any
heating for their homes and the help and
Head Start program so we got to defund
the left and stop giving money to
Catholic Charities
the second-biggest program is AARP
American Association of Retired people
know another big left-wing organization
why why do they have to be defunded well
they have to be defunded it's explained
because they happen to have a program
that's trying to help elderly people who
are hungry
get work now in fact The Wall Street
Journal had another article saying that
16 percent of the elderly are severely
malnutrition than many are literally
starving but AARP is trying to work out
some kind of program for them to get
some work so that's another left-wing
organization that has to be defunded and
so it goes on in fact if you have a look
at it it turns out that the left is
everybody who is not pathologically
insane you know that's a pretty large
number of people you know so in fact
they think the whole left is it that you
know that we want know that we've got
everybody on our side and in fact I
don't think that's completely wrong so
the it's not that the propaganda system
has you know turned everybody into a
raving lunatic no it hasn't
people keep their decent instincts but
they are very confused I mean the same
people who say we should the government
should increase you know the government
the majority of the population says the
government has a responsibility to help
the poor but another majority the
population
says the government should end welfare
well you know what's welfare well
helping the poor and here's where the
propaganda system has worked
I mean it's convinced people that we're
giving away all our money you know we're
giving all our money to foreigners we're
giving our money to black women driving
Cadillacs and you know that kind of
stuff and that kind of confusion is all
over the place and people don't know
what they want they don't know what they
think but they know what their attitudes
are and their attitudes are pretty sane
professor but you must submit that
nothing the situation have not changed
in math evaluation has not changed have
not changed since when's I mean do we
have slavery in the form okay so with no
situations changed a lot in fact
situations change a lot in our lifetimes
for the better it's a much better
country it was 30 years ago way better
and that's a very important meeting like
this could not have been held in
conceivable that it could have been held
30 years ago and now I can be held
everywhere in the country the most
reactionary place in the country with
huge mob everybody's interested and so
on and so forth those are big changes
and they reflect all sorts of things
that have happened in the country not
because you know people were writing
articles or reading books or anything
like that because plenty of people are
organized and they're organizing because
they know things and they're learning
things and they're contributing by their
actions other people learning things and
so on that has changed the country and
there's plenty of room for further
change you know things go up and back
like now it's worse than it was a couple
of years ago but that's happened before
it too 1920s were worse than now so okay
what do you see keep struggling it's my
unhappy duty to inform you that our
contract calls for us to close down ten
minutes ago so I'm I'm really sorry I
thank you all very very much for coming